all right so some of you might know that
i just quit my data science job
at fang the reason why i'm not seeing
explicitly which company
it's in case i need to go begging back
for my job you know and i don't want
them to say like oh my god why did you
say this about our company
we're not going to take you back now
before i go into why i quit my job i
kind of have to re-explain
what my role was as a data scientist and
the reason why i have to re-explain it
is because it's not as standardized as
like software engineering
which is i mean i i know i explained in
a lot of videos but i'm just gonna do it
again just so that you can have
uh the right context to understand why i
quit
so basically this was my job title
at this company and um yeah so you can
read it
so in essence in my words um a data
scientist is usually put into a product
team
and usually in the product team there's
a product manager there are software
engineers
and there's a data scientist now
obviously there are other roles you know
for example like ux researchers
and um and like product specialists
marketing people legal people and stuff
like that but i'm just gonna
you know simplify it and say okay so
there's software engineers and data
scientists
and product managers so i'm not gonna
explain it in a way where
it's like oh data scientists they make
models they use like
r and like software engineers they build
infrastructure
and they use programming languages blah
blah i'm not going to explain like that
i'm going to explain it in a more
fundamental way of what their roles
actually are
so engineers they actually have the
technical abilities to build the thing
we actually want to build
product managers they're basically the
leaders or like the owners of the
product
they decide what the product is going to
do
and also what the product should be
doing basically they have the vision
and they're in charge of actually
executing getting the [ __ ] done
and you know they'll do whatever they
need to do to actually ship a product
in some ways you could think of them as
like mini ceos of a product or a feature
and then data scientists we have the
most time to think
because we don't need to like build
anything like for engineers and stuff
like that
and we also don't need to focus on
executing and talking to
cross-functional partners all the time
so in some ways because we're able to
think more
than those two counterparts we're
basically like
advisors or like consultants of like the
product we don't actually make the final
decisions and calls i mean obviously
your opinions matter
but in in essence the the people who had
the final say
are kind of the product managers and
also the engineers because
the engineers are going to build it so
they could build whatever they want and
then product managers
um they're the ones they're the ones
that decide on
the future of the product now because we
have so much time to think our
job is to try to understand the product
inside and out we're supposed to
technically not i'm not saying all data
scientists do that
but i think that the fundamental role of
a data scientist is to understand the
product
in and out better than anyone else the
reason is because like i said
you have more time to think you have
more time in your hand so basically we
use data
to try to understand exactly what the
product needs and where the product
should go
in terms of the product direction and
what we can do is we can tell
our team exactly where we should
prioritize and how we should
do certain things why because we have so
much time to think about it you know we
don't need to build stuff we don't need
to execute on anything
so that's our role we're always making
sure
that the team is working on the most
important things
currently okay i'll do one more analogy
just because i like doing analogies
so imagine a youtube channel right um
engineers would be like video producers
which is the people who actually know
how to make videos because in the end if
you don't have a video you're not going
to have a video channel
so i think of engineers like video
producers
and then product managers i think of
product managers as
the people who well it doesn't need to
be multiple people it could just be one
person
but basically the person who sends
emails tries to look for sponsorships
and they think about okay where should
this channel go
basically they do everything that's not
related to videos you know we got
branding we got sending
emails making websites communicating
with other youtubers
basically just all the crap that video
producers
might not want to do so i think those
people are like the product managers and
then we got a data science a data
scientist would be kind of like an
uh an analyst of your youtube channel uh
what an alice would do
is they would all they always look at
analytics to make sure that
uh you know you get some insights to
know what kind of videos to make next
like for example they look at the views
and they say like okay
you know these things are kind of hot
right now or this is kind of trending
yeah you look at comments too basically
you're like you're trying to understand
your users
the best way you can using data or
anything actually
it doesn't even matter it doesn't even
need to be data so basically
those are the fundamental rows basically
a data scientist should figure out
you know how to get more subscribers how
to get more views and uh why are certain
things working or certain things not
working
so then give them insights give the
product manager or like the video
producer insights into like okay what
should you make next
how should we you know like these
strategies okay i know that was kind of
long
just to explain fundamentally what a
data scientist
is ah [ __ ] i need water
oh [ __ ] okay i'm too lazy to get water
okay
but um basically the reason why i quit
my data science job in essence
it's because i'm still exploring
so i guess what i'm trying to say is a
lot of people are content with their
first job out of college
and for my case i think
that for the first years of your college
it is totally okay
to keep searching and try to understand
yourself and try to understand
what exactly is the right fit for you in
terms of a job
like i prioritize well i might be wrong
i don't know but i prioritize
long term like uh for example if
you know i just stuck with data
scientists and in the future i realized
i hate the job
then the cost of switching jobs is a lot
higher later on if i was already five
years or six years in
so i do think that sacrificing the first
few years
trying to discover what you actually
want is definitely beneficial
for your career hopefully i don't know
we'll see so i'm not saying oh by the
way i'm switching to software
engineering i have a feeling that some
people don't know but
i'm not saying that software engineering
is my true calling or that
this is the final uh job that i want i
don't know i'm not sure i might be wrong
you know i might not even last for like
another year or two
but in the current state that i am right
now
i feel that i don't want to do
you know the analytics part like you
know the youtube guy where he just looks
at analytics i kind of want to make
videos i want to be a video producer
so in this analogy it means that i want
to build things
and i think that's currently what i want
at least what i think i want
so that's why i'm going to try out
software engineering now
and uh yeah because i've i thought that
i was always a builder
you know i do like some aspects of data
scientists but you know i want to try
to build stuff this time like i think at
the core
my personality does fit more of a
builder you know i do like building
stuff but yeah
so yeah so those are the arguments of me
wanting to become a software engineer
so i'm going to talk about some things
about why i don't want to be a data
scientist anymore
so at least at my company or my old
company
the way you get evaluated no matter what
role you have
is how much impact you have and
basically what impact means is if you
did you have like a positive
contribution to the company so
even if you worked your ass off or you
did you know you do a lot of smart
intelligent things
but it doesn't have any positive impact
to the company or like it doesn't really
change anything
then you still might get fired after a
while so as a data scientist
using the scope that i talked about like
the fundamental rows
basically um how a data scientist can
have
impact in a company like that is by uh
make
like being like influencing the product
decision
influencing the product direction so for
a data scientist using that scope of
like fundamental roles
a data scientist how they can have
impact is by
you know making analysis or something
such that it leads
into actionable insight meaning that
people will use that
insight and then they'll take action
towards it and then it'll benefit the
company
so that's impact all right so i have a
few examples i'm just gonna read it out
loud
because i i can't remember them so
basically in a simple way
if your analysis convinced the engineers
to build something
and our metrics went up that's impact
also if your analysis convinced the pm
and the team
to put a new feature a or a project on
the roadmap
that's impact if you create an amazing
prediction algorithm
to predict whether a user watched a
video with
a loan in their apartment or with
friends but the team didn't decide to
implement it because they don't think
it's useful
that is not impact if you found that
korea is a growing market for live
videos
and you have tons of evidence that
adding a donation button can make your
company dominant
in the live video market in them in
korea but even with their sound
evidence you cannot convince your
product team to focus on korea
that is not impact so as you can see
it's not always a hundred percent fair
because for some team
it might be easier than another and
there's a lot of factor that plays
into the success of a data scientist and
some of them are
out of your control and that was one
thing that i found
a little bit harder to cope with now
i've worked with teams where it was
really really easy to find
opportunities and then you show those
opportunities to them and then they're
super excited and they'll do it you know
and that's a lot of impact
but i've also worked for teams that
move a lot slower i guess more friction
and basically
you know you don't have as much
credibility to them and
and it's a lot more difficult to
convince them to do what you want to do
so that's why it's a little bit harder
so and basically if you have no
influence
you don't have impact as a data
scientist now
sometimes you might be lucky that your
work is so good that your work speaks
for itself
right but the reality is that in life
that's not always the case sometimes you
just have to be influential
basically you have to have the skills to
influence your peers
your engineering manager the product
manager you have to get them in the same
team as you or you have to basically or
basically you have to kind of convince
them
that your ideas are good and that they
should implement it
but that's the thing um it doesn't
always happen and sometimes you gotta be
pretty good at like the office politics
or like you know stuff that are more
like soft skills-ish
and i believe those were the skills i
lacked or at least that's what i thought
before and which made me
kind of like eh like believe it or not
i'm actually
kind of like a work introvert so
i'm also like still very inexperienced
in in
understanding like the work dynamics and
also like some office politics and stuff
like that i'm still quite new
so i mean i did get better but at the
time
that was what made me want to switch to
software engineering because
i felt like i wasn't ready to be a
product leader
on my team i didn't feel like i had the
maturity to make
and influence decisions on my team i
didn't have the confidence in myself
nor my work and that stressed me out
yeah that stressed me out now don't get
me wrong there's a lot of aspects of
data science that i enjoyed and that i
like and that i still like
and i do hope that when i work as a
suite that i could use some of the
things i've learned
and and use it as my advantage but
basically how i think about it like my
philosophy is that
your goal shouldn't be like oh i should
be really i should be a really good data
scientist or i should be
a really good software engineer you
should be the ultimate worker okay that
sounds kind of weird but
basically what i'm trying to say is you
want to be the guy who can solve
everything with anything
right like if there's a problem you're
the guy to solve it no matter if it's a
technical problem
a business problem or like an analytics
problem and stuff like that
you want to be the guy that people can
depend on and that's the person that i'm
trying to be
and for now the skills i want to work on
are you know building skills like a
software engineer
so yeah i mean i haven't done that in
ages i kind of miss it
okay so now what you know what am i
doing now well
i am unemployed so basically what i do
is every day i just sit on my ass
and i work on interview problems what
else have i been doing yeah so
you know because i have so much time in
my hands um
i've been going to blind a lot uh blind
is this like anonymous
uh forum app that you can check uh you
could check like gossip
so basically when i worked at like my
company x
what i could have done is i could have
gone to blind and see what other people
were talking about
that also worked at company x so
basically lots of gossip
but i also use it for non-gossip and
there's a lot of stuff that you can read
about in like normal topics
where just bunch of people from silicon
valley they just talk about random stuff
and most of the time they talk about
you know switching company interviewing
at their tc
total compensation how much they make
it's a good way for me to get a feel of
what the market is like right now so i
use it a lot
almost obsessively a lot of the times i
check like okay you know
um you know company x interview process
to kind of get a feel of like how they
interview you
so that's what i do i mean you guys
should totally check it out it's pretty
cool
um yeah lots of lots of anonymous talks
there
yeah so basically um you know i mean
i get a lot of questions sometimes from
people saying like oh how should i do x
or where
what should i do to find x y or whatever
oh wait my camera's almost done
yeah so pretty much like um i get a lot
of questions where
sometimes i don't even know the answer
but how do i get the answers
uh you know i go to google i go to you
know i'll go expert
to learn some stuff i use blind to
understand how the interview process are
like
i use a lot of these websites so i feel
like you know instead of me answering
all the questions for you guys
i should just give you the tools to
answer these questions right
so there's this quote you know what they
say give a man a fish
and you feed him for a day teach a man
how to use blind
and they'll get into a career and buy
organic fish from whole foods
for a lifetime all right that's all i
have to say for today
thanks for watching peace
[Music]